-My next guest
is a very funny comedian
whose stand-up special
"Brian Regan on the Rocks"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Here is Brian Regan!
Wow! That's what I'm talking --
Look at you.
Wow.
-Hey, Jimmy, how are you?
-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
Brian, you know
I'm a big fan of yours,
but I -- Something's different.
You look a little different.
Is it --
It's the hair. Is that new hair?
-You guys were talking about it
earlier with Luke Bryan
and about -- You know,
it's the gray hair thing.
I don't know what happened
either, Jimmy.
-New hair.
-COVID hit.
-Yeah.
-I went into hibernation,
and I came out a senior citizen.
-[ Laughs ] Wow. Oh, my gosh.
-I looked down, I was like,
"Hey, is that an AARP card?"
-[ Laughs ]
You did it! You made it.
-Yeah.
-I know that you've been
back on the road,
which is awesome,
as crowds are kind of
coming out again slowly,
and you've been traveling.
What is it like
flying these days?
-I don't know, man.
I just always think
weird things, you know.
You know when the plane
backs away from the gate?
-Yeah, sure.
-Just once,
I want the pilot
to pop open the door
and say, "Hey, put your heads
down, I'm backing up."
[ Laughter ]
-"Yeah, you know how hard it is
to pull back this thing?"
-"Yeah, get your heads down.
I'm trying to back up here.
18C, what's the matter with you?
Get your head down."
The guy's --
-What does Brian Regan do?
Are you a window seat guy,
or are you an aisle seat?
-Well, I --
I'd like to get an aisle.
I'll I try to get an emergency
exit row seat if I can do that.
-Absolutely, yeah.
-Yeah. You know
what kills me, though?
When you're in
the emergency exit row seat,
and you agree to save everyone,
how come when the flight
is over, no one thanks you?
[ Laughter ]
Pretty amazing. Pretty amazing
what you might have done,
you know? You think someone
would take note of it
on the way out, you know?
A little pat on back,
"Hey, I heard what went down
before takeoff.
Unbelievable.
The fact that you were willing
to put your life on the line
to save me, my family, and all
the other souls on this plane
is one of the greatest gifts
a human can offer to another.
Thank you
from the bottom of my heart."
No, nothing.
-Nothing at all.
-Just a backpack, a backpack
to the back of the head.
"Hey, I was
an almost-responder!"
-[ Laughs ] An almost-responder.
When you do get to your gigs,
do you have a driver,
or do you rent a car?
-[ Chuckles ] I have a driver,
He's called Brian.
-Oh, okay. Wow, yeah,
I didn't know.
-Yeah, I get -- I try to get
a rental car every now and then.
And in fact,
I had to cancel one recently.
And I called, and the guy said,
"Well, you're calling
within 24 hours,
so we need to charge you
for a day."
And I was like, "Oh, okay."
And I was like, "Hey,
am I allowed to change
the reservation?"
And he goes, "Yeah, I guess."
I said, "Alright.
I just realized I need
to pick it up 48 hours from now.
Yeah? Can you change it
officially in the computer?
Is it official? Yeah?
I want to cancel it."
[ Laughter ]
-That's the way to do it, man.
That's the way to do it, bud.
I want to talk the you about --
'Cause I know
you got your special on Netflix
"On the Rocks,"
but then you're on the --
You're part of the cast
of the show "Loudermilk"...
-Yes.
-that is fantastic, by the way.
-Thank you.
-And you're doing
some serious acting in this.
You got some chops, buddy.
-Well, I'm honored to be in it.
It's called "Loudermilk."
It's on Prime Video.
It's a dark comedy.
Peter Farrelly and Bobby Mort
co-created it.
Third season just came out.
Ron Livingston plays Loudermilk,
who runs
a substance abuse group,
and he's got a bunch of misfits
in the group,
and I fit in there perfectly.
And it's fun to be in, man.
Peter Farrelly saw me perform
at a comedy festival called
LucyFest, and he came up to me
and said that he was doing
this "Loudermilk" thing
and wanted to know
if I wanted to be in it.
So I'm honored that
he put me in this thing.
-Yeah, he actually
just was quoted somewhere
saying that this season,
you have some of the best acting
on television,
and that's Peter Farrelly,
who has won an Oscar,
I just want to remind everyone.
Not too shabby --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not too shabby, Brian Regan.
-So he got my check.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-I'm honored, man.
He's a great director.
And he gave me some fun stuff
to do in Season 3.
So I'm happy to be in it.
-Yeah, this season,
you get really in there.
I want to --
We're gonna show a clip.
Would you like
to set up this clip?
-Well, I'm an alcoholic.
I'm estranged from my family.
I'm estranged from my kids.
I'm trying to reconnect --
-Brian, I'm talking about the --
I'm talking about the TV show.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Let's get back on that.
I'm not acting in the show.
I'm just being me.
So, anyway, one of my sons
asked me to go to career day
to talk about my job,
and I'm nervous as heck.
I'm an exterminator.
When I get there, I find out
I have to follow a guy
who's a scientist
who just isolated a gene.
I'm like,
"We don't need to do this.
These kids have seen plenty."
And they're like, "No, no, no.
You're next."
So this is me trying to impress
my son and his friends.
-That's awesome.
I want to show everyone.
This is Brian Regan in the new
season of "Loudermilk."
Take a look at this.
-Well, sometimes
parents don't want skunks
knocking on their door,
so they, uh -- they call me,
and I come over, and I --
and I kill it.
[ Laughter ]
-You kill skunks?
-Yeah, yeah. I kill skunks.
I kill possums. I kill rats.
Anything with four legs or more,
I will come over to your house,
and I will kill it.
[ Laughter ]
So, are there any questions?
-What kind of person
kills animals for a living?
-That is an excellent question.
A licensed exterminator.
-You're a psychopath.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Brian Regan, everybody!
Watch all three seasons
of "Loudermilk" on Amazon Prime.